[music playing]
- Oh, [bleep]!
Go this way, go this way.
Ease, ease.
Oh, yeah.
A bear had been going through
here digging up bee nests.
Oh, another one over there!
I see bear markings on
the trees back here, too.
So if other bears are coming
through, they smell this
and they know he's the
bear that owns this place.
See he chewed up the
tree on this side?
See, this his marking post.
It goes all the way up there.
He's probably around
here, because you
see all those fresh marks where
he dug up those yellow jackets.
He's right around here.
[music playing]
This doesn't factor
into my choice
too much where I'm going to
put the camp because there's
bears everywhere around here.
But it's going to be pretty
sketchy sleeping at night.
But where I make my camp, I'm
going to determine by where
is the best access from
the river to the lake,
and seeing this big
animal trail here
tells me that the moose
used this spot because it's
the easiest place to
walk back and forth
from the lake to the river.
So what I'm thinking is this
is a prime spot to make camp.
[shimmer, music playing]
OK, Sky.
Let's get this tarp.
Just spread it out
as far as you can.
See we're going to put it
between these trees here,
and this is just
going to give us
a nice little dry spot we
could sit under or even
leave our firewood here.
Let's try to get this
done before the rain hits.
We might be using this tarp
before we even know it.
It's about two weeks out
from moose hunting season,
but it takes a lot of work,
and it takes a lot of noise
to put up a moose hunting camp.
And I want to do this early so
I'm not making all that noise
and having to do all this
work during moose hunting.
- We could set a wall tent here.
- Yeah.
Well, this is something
we could leave up.
We don't even have
to take it down.
We don't want to put a
wall tent up and walk away.
A bear might tear
the crap out of it.
This is a big step for
Skylar because he's
hunted a lot of small
game, but now he's
got to think of
the bigger animals,
and it's a lot more
dangerous hunting big game.
So he's going to have
to stick close to me
and learn all these different
moves we do out here to try
to get a good opportunity
to harvest something,
so it's exciting for him.
And now we'll stand it up.
OK, tarp's up.
Beautiful view of
the river right here.
If any moose come out,
you'll be able to see
him on the bar from here.
A little bit of gas money,
some hard work, and this
is how we put food on the
table out here in Alaska.
[music playing]